hi and welcome to episode number 50 of
the weekly Google+ on podcast I am
Franciscan boy and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mandel hey Mark how are
you doing little bit sleepy but I'm good
it's been a long day many meanings many
recordings yeah yeah yeah this is any
time of year yeah but actually a very
good interview today yeah yeah super
actually was just it was great it was
just really great we talked to two
members of dais dais dais working on the
helm project the package manager for
Cooper Nidhi's yep and it is very
interesting I really enjoyed the whole
conversation lots of history about the
project how it happened and how to use
it and I'm actually now convinced I want
to try it i'm definitely using this yeah
yeah and going on from that actually
after we talked to our people for our
interview we have a question of the week
about building docker images in the
cloud cool that is that is interesting
if especially if you're traveling around
and you have Wi-Fi from the hotel yes or
on an airplane oh yeah I've tried that
yeah yeah I've built up her images well
using go-girl with it kind of works it
works I mean it works I've done it yeah
yeah if you have a long flat enough yeah
go up but before that we get we have the
cool things of the week as usual and the
first one is about my favorite sport not
at all I actually don't know much about
this sport is baseball it's about the
coding the micro moments of baseball can
you hear the games for data so yeah this
is basically just a blog post that was
announced on Thursday October 25th by
Eric Schmidt one of our lazy people to
join our team of developer advocates for
cloud and he wrote an article about how
to basically try to understand better
what goes on in baseball games and to do
that he's using three big data products
so he's using cloud dataflow to
transform the data so cloud dataflow you
can imagine it as streams of data going
around and cannot doing MapReduce II
things but it is actually more generic
than that it is really powerful so have
a look at it I
I think we did we have a an episode on
this now doing oh do be I'm not sure now
all right yeah we've done a lot of
episodes now so it's actually getting
hard to track yeah maybe we should I
think that Google Cloud later flow is
one of my I've said this before I think
it's the only product that is the only
product at Google that will make me
write Java yeah yeah that's actually
really cool aticle they've got stuff in
here like answering questions like is
this picture performing at his best what
was the probability of the triple play
which i think is actually kind of hard
questions to answer so the cool thing
about this that you basically want
something that is a kind of real time
because you want to be able to answer
questions while the game is going on so
without data flow allows you doing that
with swimming and then to query all the
data you end up with he uses bigquery
and to be able to visualize it in a nice
way or to slice and get only the piece
of data he cares about use this google
cloud data lab and google cloud data lab
if you've never used it it is pretty
much like I Python or Jupiter pages on
the club it is very very useful
especially because then you can just sit
run a little not produce here and it
will create the whole thing for you
that's pretty cool very nice yeah sweet
well we have one more cool thing of the
week that flows on quite nicely from
windows and net episode yesterday it was
showing how you can use powershell to
basically treat Google Cloud storage
like local storage and by yesterday mark
means last week I mean last week I am
really tired huh yeah I don't know what
day it is anymore or what is going on
but that's fine but no it's it's really
nice um so yeah if you if you're using
PowerShell and you want to interact with
Google Cloud Storage you can use things
like CD and I keep wanting to say LS
because I'm a linux user but like CD and
standard Microsoft Windows e-type
directory stuff I know there yeah yeah
yeah I haven't done so yeah and that's
pretty much it I don't have many any of
them yeah yeah it is it is actually
really cool because I mean if you are a
PowerShell user basically these will
allow you to use Google Cloud Storage in
a very native and their intuitive way so
yeah it's cool like because basically
the PowerShell provider it returns the
same objects as everything else so you
can you can intermix
and do stuff like you with that i really
like there's this sentence in the in the
blockbuster says you can just trade
Google Cloud Storage like a really
really really big hard disk okay which
is what it is right it is really big it
is really big excellent well why don't
we go have a chat with the two clever
people that we have from home go led to
that sounds good so I'm very happy to
welcome to people from dears DSA
correctly I don't know I said I've
already tears whatever they'll tell us
so we have Michelle new rally sovereign
genere hi how are doing great how are
you and we also have mad butcher a
software architect at dear sir dais dais
dais okay that is a hard one so we're
going to be talking a little bit about
something pretty cool but before we
start talking about the main topic why
don't you tell us a little bit about who
are you and what you do at dais we can
start with Michelle yeah so I am
Michelle I'm a developer at dais I'm a
core maintainer on the Cooper Nettie's
home project I also code lead the Ku
Brunetti special interest group for
applications which is more commonly
referred to as cig apps nice what about
yo Matt I'm Matt butcher I'm an
architect at dais I'm one of the core
contributors on the helm project and and
one of the people who kind of came up
with the ideas behind helm you know I'm
along with working at days I also teach
occasionally at loyola university of
chicago in the cs department there and
just recently finished a book called go
in practice on go software development
co-authored that with Matt Farina cool
and obviously you have a PhD in
philosophy yeah yeah all the label we
tell you that's worthless you know
actually the trick is to go from
philosophy into software development
that's how haha actually you know what
not the first time I've heard that we
should do an episode on the philosophy
of Korra teens there we go I've been
interesting one excellent all right cool
all right so uh oh Matt you sound like
maybe the right person um for like a
high level like what is what is helm
like what does it do
was it for so helm is a package manager
for Cooper Nettie's so Cooper Nettie's
is this great system comes out at Google
kind of based on Google's Borg project
and it's it's a it's a great tool for
running applications inside of a
large-scale cluster but one of our early
pain points with it was that it's hard
to kind of set up your applications to
install them into Cooper Nettie's so we
looked around and we looked at you know
how we do this in Linux how we do it no
s10 we looked at home brew for OS 10 and
yum and apt-get for linux and we said
you know it'd be really cool to build
something like that for Cooper Nettie's
that made it possible to express the
stuff you wanted to run in Coober
Nettie's as an application package that
you could share and reuse and stuff so
at a high level yeah it's a package
manager designed for Cooper Nettie's so
what sort of applications would I be
looking to deploy like give me can you
give me some examples yeah actually I'll
let Michelle I'll let me show it sure um
you could install a variety of
applications wordpress jenkins databases
my sequel maria to be postgres so really
there's a large range so cool so I guess
that means like I'm like oh I need to my
sequel database I don't have to work out
the details of how to set that up and
best practices and things like that I
can just go to helm and be like a
hellmann's stole my sequel or something
like that yeah you could grab the helm
binary and run a search command and do
home search my sequel and you'll have a
variety of options and then you can
tweak your my sequel configuration to
your preferences and then run install to
install the actual chart so the question
I always have when I think about these
kind of like diploma managers which I
really see as I get something that helps
you deploy an application into Cooper
natives is is the default value the best
practice like if I just say yes yes yes
yes yes I will have something that
actually works in production or good
your way or is it something there was
like something to get started and then
you're going to be tuning up the the
deployment to have something that match
years case I guess I look at them as
like like your etsy files and Linux
right you want when you first install
something you want it to function enough
so that you've got a starting point to
sort of tweak it from there but is the
default always going to be the best
probably not so the trick is as chart
developers is to write these kinds of
helm chart packages that are good enough
to get people you know kind of up and
running and then help them understand
from there how they have to tweak it now
the additional problem with cluster
based software is it when you're
installing right when you're installing
something via homebrew you know you're
going to have one instance running
locally on exactly one computer every
time you type that in when you're
dealing with something like a cluster
you may want to be running one instance
of postgres for example or you may want
to be running a cluster of six postgres
servers with a master you know elected
out of that pool or something like that
so the trick with setting up default
sensible defaults is to sort of into it
what the base case is for most users and
then make it easy enough that they can
extend it off the base case with very
very little effort right so you use a
word there you said they were chart can
Michelle would you want to explain what
a chart is like what what is that yeah
so a chart is basically a package format
for helm it's a directory structure that
consists of somatic data template adore
not templated kuber Nonis resources and
some documentation and so applications
come in the form of charts and then you
install charts into your cluster using
helm why are they cool chutz oh that's a
very good question not better I'm gonna
let you take that one well so when we
very first started the helm project our
first name for it was actually Kate's
place k 8 k 8 s place which we thought
was kind of cute yeah in the original
the original name of the package
was something like K cubed k 3 or
something like that it was really
pretentious and as we got talking about
it we thought all right so we've got
this cute name Kate's place in this
pretentious package name and neither
really fit the nautical thing of theme
of Cooper Nettie's where Cooper Nettie's
really means a pilot of a ship so so we
hit the nautical dictionary one of my
one of the cofounders of the project
Jack Francis and I hit a nautical
dictionary and SAT around for about an
hour reading definitions trying to come
up with a new name for the tool and we
eventually alighted on helm as the name
for the tool and then once we were going
with this nautical dictionary we
couldn't let good enough rest so we
decided to rename the package to and and
we were kind of thinking well this is
sort of like a road map or a street map
for how you would install something into
Cooper Nettie's and our the CEO of deus
is a big sailor himself bover like has
likes enjoys boating and he said you do
not talk about them as maps their charts
nautical charts and the name stuck so
this a nice name yeah I like it yep I
was got to say it's short it's catchy
it's relatively direct as far as
conveying that you're providing a set of
instructions for how to do something I
guess that that segue is kind of into an
interesting thing as well the history of
helm I think there was there was helm
and then there was deployment manager
and now there's home classic or they
melded and merged like what happened
there I don't I didn't quite follow it
all yeah it's actually a really cool
history it's one you don't get a lot in
the open source world um so a little
over a year ago now day has started this
helm project it actually came out of a
hackathon we were having a and on All
Hands off-site meeting and we set up a
hackathon to try and come up with some
good competitive projects to kind of
build teamwork and and and just enjoy
some time together so we formed these
kind of ad hoc teams and we were
building stuff well my team built this
little package manager ii think the
Kate's place thing I was talking about
before and you know the the off-site
ended and we
all went home and it was a Friday
afternoon and I got a call from the CTO
saying you know that little hackathon
project has some potential maybe we
should start to actually develop it and
so the following Monday after he got
back we formed up a new team and started
going on this now what we didn't know at
the time was that several Google
engineers were also working on a similar
project which was a port of the gcp
deployment manager project to Coober
Nettie's and so for a few months we were
roughly running in parity with them and
our emphasis at the time was the de
client-side experience we were trying to
build homebrew where a lot of the
packages are just downloaded locally and
then you're really oriented around the
relationship between an individual user
and a chart which is what we were
calling him at that point whereas
deployment manager was really dealing
more with the process of deployment in
the process of allowing a teamed
together collaborate on how something
could be deployed and then updated and
maintained over over over its lifetime
so that was about October for us last
year deployment manager I think had its
first public release on November first
if I recall correctly well sometime
around january Google Seattle invited us
to come up and the developers of
deployment manager sat down with us and
we talked about how we might be able to
do something that happens very rarely in
the open source world which is to merge
two projects and so we put together a
really rough plan there and sort of
wreaking started the project off and we
all liked the hell name because it was
relatively distinctive so we kept that
and sort of rebranded as helm and then
gradually what was the helm client
stayed the home client but what was the
deployment manager server became tiller
which is the server side component the
cluster side component of of helm right
now well in in the process of all of
this well we had this original tool that
was already kind of prop popular called
helm and so we rebranded that one to
helm classic so that people could still
continue using it while we explored
uncharted waters to keep playing up this
nautical head oh yeah
no I'm loaded with a bun all the fun
yeah and and so so helm classic was kind
of the the original version of it and
then the coup brunette ease helm version
which is in the crew brunette ease
project and is incubated as an official
Cooper Matty's project that's the one
that we're really moving forward and
firing full steam ahead on hahaha wow I
don't get it I'm gonna just keep trying
these nautical letter words until I run
out of them that I'm looking forward the
next hahahaha sir so I had a question
regarding the the bond of you so you
were talking that helm has a deep focus
on the user on the customer right but
and curious about what if i have an
application that i would like to offer
on helm as a chart what is the process
to do that yes so there's two ways to
publish or two avenues you can take to
publish your chart and the first one is
you can build your own chart repository
so charts live in chart repositories
which are just simple HTTP servers that
follow a particular format and or you
can submit your chart to the Cooper
Nettie's chart repository and so if you
go to github com /q burn any / totes we
have the source code for stable charts
and incubator charts that people have
submitted over the last few months to
share with the community and so if you
have a chart that you you know it's
working and you want to get feedback on
you might submit it to the incubator
chart repository and if you have a more
of a production-ready chart that hat
that meets deep technical requirements
then you would submit it to the stable
chart repository so what actually goes
into a chart can you can you go a little
like if I'm writing one is there like a
template language or something like with
what's the is it a gamma phi gamma file
yeah what was he owes and everything a
yellow file now yeah hopefully not Jason
anymore yep I'm gonna let butcher take
that one because he developed
oh right all of that I was gonna let you
take that one so I didn't have to answer
it no so uh a chart is a bundle of plain
text files really for the most part it
references a docker image that's got to
be pushed to a registry somewhere or
could reference a docker image i should
say but really yeah it's got a control
manifest it sort of tells you
information about the chart I've read me
file a notes file but tell you kind of
how to use the chart and then for the
most part the real meat of the chart is
a set of ya moul templates there you go
there's the amyl right we use the go
template language to to be able to
populate yamel files and then we can
upload the EML files directly into
Cooper Nettie's and Coburn Eddie's
understands those files natively so the
go template language has been pretty
nice for us because it's it compiles
very well and and usually gives
relatively helpful error messages and I
knows very fast for us and we can
sandbox it very efficiently without
having to worry about breakout
conditions and things but you know your
typical chart runs probably for
templates and then the chart um will
control file and then a couple of text
files to explain how to use it oh and
and actually in order to kind of get
started with it because i know you led
with that question we originally
realized that we realized very quickly
that it's a pain to keep writing yambol
files over and over again and on top of
that there are a lot of patterns that
really are common across many many
charts so we built a command called helm
create that will allow you to create a
new chart so you can type in helm create
WordPress and you'll have a stubbed out
chart ready to go and then you can just
modify it from there instead of having
to start afresh each time cool all right
so say I've written my chart or I've
gone to look at the what is it the
stable or the incubating charts and I
want to install one what is that look
like so when you install the helm tool
by default we give you access to the
stable charts so you can simply do a
home search on whatever keyword or you
can do a home search and pass in the
repository name and you'll see all of
the
charts that are available and then if
you want to add say your friends chart
repository to search through those as
well then you can run a home repo add
command to add that repository and then
you can search through those as well and
can I pass variables through like I know
you said it was a sort of templating
thing what sort of controls do I have
there yeah so that by default when
you're setting up your templates one of
the files it's good to provide with it
is sort of a default values file which
is called values Y Amal because we're
really into our EML files uh and and the
values not yeah Mel is basically you can
think of it sort of like as the etsy
file for your for your chart right it
contains ya moul data that gets pushed
by default through the template engine
but more than that it's sort of like a
way for us to expose to developers hey
here are the different little options
that you can tweak and change easily
with this chart by just passing in your
own custom gamal file or your own custom
gemmell values when you run the
installer so say I've got my you know my
wordpress chart and I want to create my
admin user account of when I do the
install I don't want the default
password for that account so when I type
in the helm install command i can either
give it a gamal overrides file littles
it'll override the configuration for
that and maybe set user name colon and
butcher for that or i can use the set
flag on the command line and set very
particular configuration parameters but
in either case really what we're doing
is we're allowing the the end user the
person who's consuming the chart to be
able to specify some of their own
configuration custom right from the
get-go cool I got a fun question if I do
a Helmand stole is it idempotent like if
I'm not if I'm like yeah if I'm like
trying to set up some infrastructure and
I'm automating it and I just want to
keep running it over and over again is
that is that the way it works so so we
actually that originally we didn't do it
that way but over time it has been more
and more popular to be able to deploy
helm charts bsci CD and so we have
introduced first of all a renewed effort
to try and make them more
item potent and also added some
additional flags in there that will
allow you to run one command so he'll
install we'll put your chart into the
into the cluster and it'll start
tracking that chart over time so you can
recover history and so on and then he'll
update is used to kind of re-release
over and over air release updates you
change a configuration value you run an
update you go from version 1.2 point
three two one point three point four you
run an update but in order to make it
possible to run it through a CI CD
system over and over again without
having to query the cluster first we
just added some flags on to the update
command that basically if you do he'll
update dash dash install it tells update
hey try and update this but if it
already exists just install it first and
if it already exists so if it don't
resonate backwards yeah I got it
backwards install it if it doesn't exist
updated if it dies there we go yeah I
know my I can speak hahaha also that
command is upgrade so just up till I
said okay okay so helm upgrade install
okay cool so I have a question before
we're talking about helm as a way for
application developers basically to
provide a easy way to deploy their
application on to cover natives but now
you're talking about CIC d it makes me
think is it also a good tool for someone
that like a company that they're using
their own system to the blood and
communities through see icd good that'd
be easier than just using crew benetti's
files like just plain carbon Eddie's
config files I think that the the way
that CI CD systems get used is as sort
of a well for sure kind of last mile
piece of your equation right so as a
developer I need to build my application
than I want to be able to test it
locally and figure out how it's going to
work then I want to you know contribute
it up to the repo and then the CIC d
system takes over from there and what
helm gives you the advantage that helm
early confers in this process over say
just raw manifest files actually there's
several but the first one is that it
gives the developer that opportunity to
fully test out and work together work
this whole thing together share it with
other developers and things like that
prior to it ever getting deployed but
then once we get into the release
pipeline this is where a chart ends up
being very powerful because a chart is
basically immutable from the time you
package it up where it can get tracked
first of all in inside of the cluster
but also in these chart repositories
elsewhere and so I can if I'm pushing
things into repositories and then
pulling them out in cic d I've got the
exact records and will in you know the
repository of what thing I pulled out
and I can pull it out rebuild it and so
on I've seen a lot of cases where people
very successfully use just Rock who are
Nettie's manifest files in there see I
CD system but where it becomes
problematic for them is in a development
process where oftentimes we end up we
fall back to the old old school model of
throwing applications over the wall
where developers develop the application
and another team is responsible for sort
of the dev ops team is responsible for
packaging that and then somehow pushing
out to the cluster but then when you
come up with those bugs that seem to
inevitably arise where something fails
as it goes through the staging of
production process and a developer
simply says hey I only wrote the binary
the rest of that stuff is yours and then
there's this long back and forth over
whose responsibility it is and what your
particular compliance regulations say
you can see about the production logs
versus and we feel like by packaging
things just like debian end and fedora
and all of those have done for years and
years we gain all those advantages of
being able to reproduce locally
reproduce the same exact thing in a
testing environment and then in
production I guess that that makes a lot
of sense to it tena solves that problem
that I've seen where it's like oh
locally i want to have two instances of
this and two instances of that and like
one instance of that but then in
production i want to have 300 of this
and 300 of that and so now you can you
know maybe your defaults or two but
you're in production environment
variables are 300 so my next question is
can i deploy to mini cube yes you can
absolutely okay that makes for a very
interesting development experience I
guess yeah try this the session is
really really cool I think I think about
half of the development team uses mini
cube for their development process we
try and mix it up a little bit but
honestly the barrier to entry for mini
cube is so low that we all sort of favor
it and don't like trying to set out
you know local Cooper Nettie's clusters
from scratch or anything like that but
between mini Cuban gke you know the
Cooper Nettie's world is just way too
easy to get going on now nice now let's
talk about i think it's it's really
interesting in philly important thing to
i believe you can sign charts so they're
like verified from where they come from
come on if you tell us a little bit more
about that yeah michelle is is going to
point at me because this is one of those
things that i have been rather insistent
on you know it is it is often the case
that we forget about some of the
security measures to begin with and then
we try and retrofit them back in later
and and we're always afraid of doing i'm
sure we're going to have to do that in
some areas or another but one of the
things we decided we wanted to not
overlook at the beginning was the trust
factor when it came to packages so so in
thinking through this thing we thought
all right well we want to make it so
that there are ways to establish trust
where you can say i know this package
came from so-and-so and i know that it
hasn't been modified since then but on
the flip side we wanted to make it so
that people who were not who are in the
development cycle or who didn't didn't
particularly care about that kind of
thing didn't have to use it and so we
came up with a model that allows for
signing of packages and also allows you
to sort of optionally enable this kind
of work flow so that it becomes sort of
standard for you so the way we modeled
it was really after Debbie ins a model
with a little bit of looking at yaman
the way that Red Hat has done it for a
long time and we we sign packages with
PGP keys so that we can establish some
identity and and the clear sign block
you know contains the sha256 sums of the
files that are included so you can
verify those sort of a very very very
traditional uninspired someone once told
me in regard to this and I'm well you
know okay well uninspired is ok
insecurity I think yep um but then so
you can choose to sign your charts if
you want and then you can choose to
verify your charts when you install them
if you want and then more recently we've
been working on sort of integrating this
tool chain with things like key base I'm
really
cited about key base because it makes
public key cryptography sort of easy for
for non cryptographers right easy to
gain trust on your identity easy to you
know integrate your GP g keen key with a
reliable key signing Authority stuff
like that and so we've been working a
little bit on that but then at the end
of the day we've been trying to figure
out sort of how now that we've got these
primitives right how do organizations
want to be able to use this technology
and so we've tried to keep it unattended
issue your keys and how you should sign
your packages and how you should tell
people how to do that that's going to be
an ongoing challenge for us up through
the 2 point 0 release I think cool so
since we talked about two point O
releases and the future why haven't you
could you share something that you're
very excited about the roadmap being
able to test your charts once you've
installed them automatically like that
is something that I am super pumped
about so you can install your chart and
then run a test command that will that
has some predefined definitions of what
it means for for success or for a
successful installation of your chart
being able to do that in an automated
way something that I'm I'm very pumped
about cool what about you met uh i'm
honestly looking forward to hitting the
stability marker because because because
it'll give me a little bit of a break
from implementing stuff but i think
other than testing which i am really
really excited about Michelle's plan for
that is really cool I think that what I
would what I'm kind of looking forward
to is getting to focus a little bit more
on the developer experience for the
person who's actually writing the code
that's going to get packaged up into
these applications because as a as a
Python developer right it would be nice
to be able to have some tools even if
they're meta tools that sit on top of
helm that will help me get from my
little block of python code to a
containerized
application that with a chart
scaffolding around it that I can deploy
with you know the helm install command
cool well we are running out of time a
little bit but i do want to cut touch on
one thing so if people want to get
involved with him or they want to try
home where that one of the best
resources we should people go the github
repository is definitely the best place
to start and all of their release
binaries are there you can use homebrew
to download download helm and install
home the slack channel is really active
i looked yesterday and there were four
hundred and sixty six people in the helm
channel in the cooper nutty slack and
everybody's very actively discussing and
analyzing chart design patterns and
figuring things out and bouncing ideas
off each other so that's a great place
to go if you've got questions as always
the issue queue I do highly recommend
because I'm biased to come to the cig
apps meetings on mondays Matt usually
gives us a home update there and there
are and there have been several demos of
charts and helm a used in CI CD and
really all over the place so if you want
to see use cases say copses is the place
to go see gaps is also a great place
just to see cool demos of what people
are doing with Cooper Nettie's it's a
great entry point into into Cooper
Nettie's yeah the focus of cig apps is
mainly to share with the community how
to define run and manage applications in
Coober Nettie's and so it's a mix of
curious users and q brunette ease
developers and what we get is this rich
feedback loop of users saying here that
here are the tools we're using here the
problems we're running into and then
developer is going well I can fix your
problem or let me know what features you
want and discussing those kinds of
things cool all right we are definitely
running out of time but uh it is there
anything else that we haven't talked
about that you want to talk about
quickly that hasn't been touched on or a
feature that you think should be
publicly talked about oh well for sure
we should we should thank the community
around
because it was you know like i said i
can't think of many open-source projects
that have formed by two other projects
combining together and people have just
dropped in to help all over the place
from dozens of companies bitnami and
Google in particular have contributed
vast amounts of help and resources
bitnami and Google together I've now
taken over ownership of the charts
repository which has been fabulous and
you know we just every day we watch
people come in sometimes they make a
one-line commit to the docs sometimes
they just bring up situations we've
never heard of its a really fun
laid-back and awesome community and we'd
be remiss if we didn't thank them every
opportunity we had because it's just
such a fun thing to do day after day
Michelle I have to say the same thing
actually this is my first time being a
part of a larger scale open source
community and it's been a fantastic
experience have gotten the chance and
the opportunity to meet so many cool
people from different companies that
just want to help and and that's been a
fantastic experience for me that is
awesome I think that is a great way to
finish our interview so thank you so
much for taking the time to teach us and
talk to us about helm and charts and all
the nautical puns hahaha yeah thank you
guys very much for having us thanks so
much for such an excellent interview uh
Michelle and Matthew that was fantastic
I'm really really excited to sit down
and play with him now yeah that was lots
of fun and actually won once we finish
the interview we were discussing about
something really cool that we didn't
mention which is the something that we
use the cool thing of the week like a
couple months ago probably it is the
little guide to crew benetti's that came
up from the same hackathon as helm so
we'll have a link on that but it's
basically the cutest guy to learn in
Cooper Nettie's you could ever imagine
yeah it's adorably Illustrated yeah it
and it is actually technically accurate
so yeah yep definitely worth checking so
I think it's time to go for our question
of the week so the question of the week
today is a
docker images in the club and basically
it is okay so I have something that I
have an image that I want to build
regularly so I imagine that for instance
you have something you have a project
and every single time you have a comment
on github you want to create a new image
and there's ways of doing that this but
either like a Google cloud platform way
of doing it yeah so there is totally a
Google cloud platform way of doing it we
have this service it's currently in beta
called Google Cloud container builder it
is literally exactly what you described
it as it's a REST API that you can send
a series of commands to and the final
output is a docker container image which
then gets served up to G cRIO so like
our google container registry and so
it's a really nice way of if you're
using google containers registries and
you have like a CI or CD system or some
sort of automation for building these
contain your images it's an easy way of
basically saying hey I would like to
build one of those push that up into
into the container registry and then I
want to serve that maybe to container
engine compute engine App Engine
flexible environment anywhere from there
yeah I think it is a is a pretty
interesting thing to mention a little
bit about Google container registry so
Google container registry for throws
that might have never heard about it it
is just a container registry so nothing
really fancy in there but it is private
so only only your project your goal
klappa from Project has access to it so
it basically removes all the issues on
oh I wanna I wanna have a docker image
and I want to be able to pull it from
somewhere but I don't want to make it
public I don't want other people to see
it so it is a very good solution for
that yeah and of course that also ties
into all of our security stuff as well
so you ready no it's secure and you can
control who accesses and whatnot so it's
pretty awesome and it is also in the
same network so the deployment will be
faster and all the goodness yeah yep so
that's pretty cool all right um I think
that kind of brings us to our end what
are you up to where are you going what
are you doing so by the time the podcast
comes out I'll be probably on my way to
the airport to fly to Brazil I be going
to florianópolis to speak at gopher come
brazil and the week after that I'll
still be in Brazil
this time in Sao Paulo to speak and
actually kind of organized which is lots
of fun tcp neck sao paulo we're going to
be talking about all the new things that
we're working on for google cloud
platform so the keynote will be a live
stream so we'll have a link and that so
in case you want to check it out that
will be in november 10th what about you
i'm doing a lot less than that
thankfully so when this comes out i will
be at the United conference the unity
conference just be attending so please
feel free to say hello after that I
think I'm done I think I'm not traveling
again for a while wow I say that now but
it'll change yeah I was gonna say wow so
lazy but at the same time I don't
believe it so thanks again one more time
for for recording an episode with me and
this is actually our number 50 episode
yeah which is kind of crazy that's
amazing yeah and it would just passed
our first anniversary recording it the
podcast yeah the first morning yeah it's
been a long long time yeah and since
then I lost my accent completely
completely I don't hear it let you
absolutely yeah yeah so thank you and
thank you all for listening yeah and see
you all next week
you